sobre qué intervalo 7x tiene una razón
de cambio promedio de menos 4 entonces
la razón de cambio promedio si tú
piensas en el promedio
por ejemplo en esta sección aquí mismo
la pendiente es muy muy vertical luego
menos vertical aquí menos negativa menos
negativa aquí es 0 luego es positiva más
positiva y más positiva y más positiva y
cuando llegas a este punto puedes ver
que estás donde había comenzado y el
promedio puedes decir que el cambio
promedio cambio neto ácido 0 y en el
intervalo en donde el cambio neto ha
sido 0 también te dice que la razón de
cambio promedio va a ser cero entonces
puedes ver que en la razón de cambio
promedio es realmente la pendiente de la
línea es la pendiente de la línea que
conecta a los dos puntos finales del
intervalo
otra manera de preguntar sobre qué
intervalo de x tiene una razón de cambio
promedio de menos 4 es si tú puedes
encontrar un intervalo el cual la
pendiente entre sus dos puntos finales
es igual a menos 4 así que veamos las
opciones que nos han dado el primer
intervalo es que x esté entre menos uno
y uno
entonces x está entre menos uno aquí x
es igual a menos uno cuando x es igual a
menos 17 x está aquí tiene menos 1 es
igual a 7 y luego cuando x es igual a 1
cuando x es igual a 1
nuestra gráfica está aquí abajo que de 1
es igual a menos 1 entonces cuál es la
pendiente de la línea que conecta a los
puntos finales estos 2 estos dos puntos
cuál es la pendiente de la línea que
conecta esos dos puntos porque la
pendiente de esta línea la línea que
conecta los puntos finales de mi
intervalo
va a ser la razón de cambio promedio
sobre este intervalo y podemos ver
claramente que la pendiente aquí la
razón de cambio de g con respecto a x es
menos 4 cada vez que nos movemos uno
hacia adelante en la dirección x nos
movemos 4 hacia abajo en la dirección y
nos movemos uno hacia adelante en la
dirección x nos movemos 4 hacia abajo en
la dirección que entonces la razón de
cambio promedio sobre este intervalo es
menos 4 así que tenemos que indicar que
este intervalo va a funcionar